when a democratic president
is in power
very often fox news
talks about the war on christmas a lot
and we now have a pandemic which has
affected holidays for some time and fox
news is going absolutely crazy over very
milk toast comments that anthony fauci
made i'm gonna play the clip for you
that started it all dr fauci was asked
over the weekend
are christmas gatherings good to go and
he
responding to a question said it's just
too early to say
but we can gather for christmas or it's
just too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time fauci didn't cancel
christmas he didn't even come out and
say i must talk about christmas
he was asked a question and he said it's
just kind of early fox news has now been
going for 48 hours with the idea that
fauci is canceling christmas look at
these clips here is uh jason rantz
who is a radio host in seattle listen to
this unhinged insanity 75 or so to tell
me that it's not safe to visit your
family for christmas to say that now in
october indicates this isn't really
about public health at this point now
we're talking about taking total control
now understand what he did there this
guy's saying in october fauci is saying
no christmas no
in october found she's saying christmas
is too far away to talk about christmas
we just need to see what's happening
with the virus
uh another example here is
i think this is kennedy
saying why is fouchy talking about
christmas well he was asked about it he
didn't come up with the question problem
is he's talking about christmas and
hanukkah we haven't gotten to halloween
and thanksgiving columbus kids thank you
dana we're getting rid of that kids did
not get to have a halloween last year
right and it's like you know you have
little kids you only have so many of
them my daughter last year had to bake a
twilight cake with little gravestones
okay yeah making drama where there is no
drama why is fouchy talking about
christmas
because he was asked by margaret brennan
about christmas that that's why
then the histrionics really get going
with tucker carlson tucker
it's it's incredible what tucker is able
to do with this the histrionic nature of
this take a look there was do not travel
for christmas anthony fauci said do not
congregate together to celebrate it that
means no christmas eve in church that
means no christmas morning under the
tree with your it's an attack on
religion like tearing through stockings
it means no christmas at all
sacred christian observance canceled
until further notice from dr anthony s
fauci md
what a thrill it must have been for him
to say something like that oh yeah
here's a guy who fully expected to spend
his life giving prostate exams and there
he was declaring the ancient christian
calendar null and void by the way is
what it was uh
was fouchy heading towards urology as a
spa i don't even know what the prostate
exam thing even is so tucker blowing it
completely out of the water here's
another right wing guy clay travis
um
saying fauci's just trying to control
holidays
new one uh but i have to say
that fauci there the constitution
matters the most in times of emergency
and crisis because that's when the
foundation of our country's documents
matter the absolute most uh imagine
dr fauci
what do you think about christmas i
don't know it's too soon to tell this
guy is attacking the constitution and
the idea that he's trying to argue to us
that we can't celebrate christmas
together and now he's saying oh i didn't
say that but you did say it he didn't
say it he didn't say it he said it's
just too soon to tell
and then lastly
here is one more of these and it's just
more pathetic than the last yes after
calling for the cancellation of
christmas again
somehow anthony fauci still has his job
never happened
just never happened and this is how the
narratives start and continue this one
has the same texture as the dr seuss who
by the way is not a medical doctor folks
you should know about that these people
are pathetic but they don't have
anything else so this is what they're
doing
remember that on tuesday october 19th we
will be doing a live viewer town hall it
will be streaming live exclusively only
on the pacman live youtube channel which
you can find
at youtube.com pacmanlive it won't be
streaming on facebook
it won't be streaming on tick tocks
it won't be on the main youtube channel
it won't be on twitch the pacman live
channel 6 pm eastern on tuesday october
19th everybody can call in
members on our website get priority will
be a great event and i hope to see all
of you then let's take a quick break and
we have quite a program planned for you
today
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off and free shipping when
you go to four sigmatic dot com slash
pacman the link is right underneath this
video